if you go to the big questions once
again you said you've um you're with
Einstein that you believe in the god of
Spinosa yes uh so you know that's a view
that God is like the universe and is
reveals himself through the laws of
physics or as Einstein said through the
lawful Harmony of the world yeah I would
agree that that God of the simulator or
whatever the the Supreme Being or beings
um
um reveal themselves through the physics
you know they're creators of this
existence and it's incom upon us to try
to understand more about this wondrous
creation like who created this thing
who's running this thing like embodying
it into a singular question with a sexy
word on top of it is like focusing the
mind to understand it it does seem like
there's a um again it could be an
illusion it seem like there's a purpose
that there's an underlying master plan
of some kind it seems like there may not
be a master plan in the sense so this's
like maybe an interesting answer to the
question of determinism versus free will
is that if we are in a
simulation the reason that the the these
higher beings would hold a simulation is
to see what happens mhm so it's not um
they don't know what
happens uh otherwise would hold the
simulation mhm so when when humans
create a simulation so it's basx and
Tesla we create simulations all the time
um especially for the rocket you you uh
you know you have to run a lot of
simulations to understand what's going
to happen because you can't really test
the rocket until it goes to space and
you want it to work so you have to you
have to
simulate subsonic transonic hyp
supersonic
Hypersonic um
ascent and then coming back super high
Heating and um overal Dynamics all this
has got to be simulated
so uh because you don't get very many
kicks at the can but we run the
simulations to see what happens not if
we knew what happens we wouldn't run the
simulation MH so if if there's so
whoever created this
existence um
is they're running it because they don't
know what's going to happen not because
they
do